By now who hasn't heard of Hong-man Choi?
Mr. Choi is without doubt one of the largest men fighting anywhere in the world.
Also known as Techno Goliath for his love of techno music and dancing,...
...Hong-man stands 7 feet 2 inches (218 centimeters) tall and weighs 360 pounds (163 kilograms).
After winning all of the top events in Korean wrestling (ssirum) and then retiring from it,...
...Hong-man now is winning fights in the K-1 Grand Prix...
...and just missed winning the 2005 championship in Japan.
Although new to the sport,...
...Hong-man has a winning record and is only expected to become better with time.
K-1 was first staged in Japan in 1993, and has earned popular culture status within this country.
The name K-1 is derived from its inclusion of a wide array of martial arts,...
...such as karate, kung fu, and kickboxing and is also known as Mixed Martial Arts.
MMA, sometimes dubbed a "fighting sport",...
...has been at the center of a controversy for its violent nature,...
...but its popularity continues to increase and one very big reason is Hong-man Choi!